more companies are promising to increase
representation in the workplace and now
a new book offers a guide on where to
start a report on more than 800
companies from various industries found
that 76 percent had no diversity or
inclusion goals at all diversity equity
and inclusion consultant deanna singh
has conducted diversity training for
non-profits and fortune 500 companies
her book is called action speak louder a
step-by-step guide to becoming an
inclusive workplace deanna so glad you
could join us here good morning good
morning to you it's a pleasure to be
here with you well you you really dig in
here because you talk about your own
experiences about uh your ideas being
stolen about being passed over in the
workspace how did all that inform this
read
you know really when i come to this work
i come to it from a very personal
perspective and a very professional
perspective on the personal side i
actually am a biracial woman and so my
mom is african-american my dad is asian
indian they met and got married after
knowing each other for just three months
and didn't even speak the same language
yes and they've been married for over 40
years wow i know i know and so one of
the things that i got to learn at a very
early age is that when you're able to
create inclusive environments right
these two people who on paper shouldn't
have been able to make it work did and
did it really well you can create so
many amazing things so from a personal
perspective i've got to watch that my
entire life but i've also seen in the
professional world how that same idea
sometimes doesn't really translate right
when you are a person from a
marginalized community and being a woman
of color and walking into spaces where i
had leadership roles and just feeling
like i wasn't seen
right
my ideas weren't as valued i i couldn't
really get to where i knew i should be
or where i was hoping to get to or as
fast as i should have been able to and
so i think it was really the the tug of
knowing and the personal side the what
can happen and the possibilities and the
professional side just seeing that
people were being held back from really
fully thriving understanding that oh if
we could just do this right if we could
just get people to start thinking about
their workplaces more inclusively people
could thrive yeah but think i mean
speaking about not being seen i was
really struck by that data point in the
introduction about how most companies 76
have no inclusion or diversity goals i
mean you you can't improve on something
that you're not tracking you don't need
knowledge so i mean i mean i guess the
best read of what they're doing is
they're just trying to be fair to
everyone and letting the chips fall
where they may but i mean what holds a
company back from setting goals and then
holding themselves accountable you know
i think there's a lot of fear in this
space and unfortunately what we've done
is we've kind of moralized you know the
the conversation around diversity equity
and inclusion if you are a person who
understands it you're a good person and
if you're somebody who doesn't you're a
bad person and what's unfortunate about
that is that what it does is it takes us
away from being able to have a
conversation about this being just
another skill
right if you're a good leader you know
how to create an inclusive environment
it's the same kind of thing that we
would look at for any other skill set
and
it's unfortunate that we've done it that
way and i think because we have
moralized it people are afraid right
they're afraid to have the conversation
they're afraid to get into the
conversation and that fear holds them
back from being able to pull this into
their strategy i think that that a lot
of people talk about this idea that we
live in a meritocracy in the fallacy of
that in and of itself but
more importantly why is it important to
have a diverse and inclusive environment
in the workspace what are the dividends
yeah so there's a lot of things but one
of the things that i would just say is
that you know there's a lot of people
who say well we do have a diverse
community or we have a lot of diversity
in our organization and that's fine and
good but it's actually not enough right
because in order for you to be able to
be really effective and get kind of the
benefits of the dividends right the
dividends are you can be more innovative
you will recruit more people more people
be interested in your organization you
don't actually get that unless people
feel included
one quick question as we run a time if
you're an employee at a company and you
don't think your company is doing well
you have a kind of a tough question for
yourself do i speak up maybe draw
attention to myself or do i not what's
your advice there my first piece of
advice is read the book because what i
tried to do in action speak louder is
really make sure that there were
tangible things that no matter where you
sat in the organization whether you were
the leader of the organization or
whether you were working in the company
whether you just started have been there
for 50 years right that everybody could
take some of the tidbits there and use
them uh to move forward vienna singh
step one read the book
action speak louder on sale right now
we'll be right back thank you